Speaker 1: All right, let's go to Tom from
Jersey. Listen, if there's ever been a time
to go to New Jersey for. For saving us, I think
it's right now. Tom from Jersey, what's going on?
Speaker 4: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can. Thank goodness.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I was going where it goes like
this is like a may maybe the next one up, but I'm
just me. I live in Jersey, which is a blue state.
I'm really happy with how our state government
functions. But there is one issue I have that
I've also noticed is an issue with a lot of other
blue states. And I think that someone from The New
York Times is saying about this. Okay. New Jersey,
for being the most diverse state in the country is
also school was one of the most segregated. And in
Connecticut, it was also three liberal state. It's
I believe is the state with the largest income
disparity because you have like wealthy people
live in Stamford. Yep. Right next to low income
people who live in Newport. I mean, and a new
Bridgeport and New Haven. Correct. And Washington.
They have really, really favorable corporate tax
rates for like Amazon. And in California, they
talk about the housing. But whenever they try to
build multifamily or single or affordable housing,
a lot of people who live in like San Francisco
or stuff get really upset. So why do you think
we have seen this issue of these liberal states
or people who live in these liberal areas who
just seem to be helping push inequality or helping
or not super invested in trying to tax systems or
reform systems that cause this type of inequality?
Speaker 1: Not saying the answer is an interesting
one. This has been studied. So if I understand
correctly, Tom, the main question you're asking is
it's liberals and blue states that
talk about fixing income inequality,
yet it's many of those very blue states that
have the most income inequality, right? I mean,
is that more or less what you're saying?
Speaker 4: Yeah, basically.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So two things on that.
Number one, the examples you're giving are
absolutely accurate when it comes to particularly
Connecticut. However, if you zoom out and look at
the country in total. It's only slightly worse of
an issue overall in blue versus red states. The
inequality issue, it is an issue. So you're right
in your analysis, but it's only to a relatively
small degree. So on average, blue states are a
little more unequal than red states, but not by a
huge margin. But it's sort of a result of the fact
that blue states are economically more successful.
And it's basically a result of the fact that on
average, blue states have higher incomes, average
incomes, and that is pulled up by blue states
having more wealthy people. And that increases
the level of inequality by virtue of having those
additional wealthy people. So it's a result,
both of the successes of those very policies
and the fact that that is what increases the
very inequality that these states want to fix.
Speaker 4: Okay. I always knew. Yeah, I never.
I always knew that we were better at it than
the red states. But I always thought to myself,
just because we're better than them
doesn't mean we shouldn't look into it.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. If you Google liberal
states and income inequality, you'll find a ton of
good resources on this have been widely studied.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I mean, but, you know,
I'd never want to live in a red state,
state in Jersey or New York my whole life.
Speaker 1: All right, well,
that's. You're right, my friend.
Speaker 4: All right. Have a great day.
Speaker 1: Okay. Thank you. There's Tom
from Jersey. Tom is not leaving Jersey is the
message we are getting, or he'll go to New York,
which is also completely fine. All right. Let's
take a very quick break. I'm taking more calls.
It's just I need a very quick break. Hang
on and then we'll get right back to it.